Pokemon Sun and Moon is only two months
away but we've just learned about even
more new creatures and features I'm Tony
and this game spot news update comes
straight from the Aloha region we
learned a lot from the new sun and moon
trailer first we've got a chubby a lolla
form of Radek eight plus new pokemon
type null and jang mo oh we also caught
a glimpse of you vo 11 of the mysterious
new ultra beasts found across the game
they're being studied by the aether
foundation a new faction that tries to
help the Pokemon harmed by the evil team
skull and speaking of characters deck
CEO and sign up from x and y versions
appear in sun and moon with a side quest
that involves finding parts of the
legendary zygarde as for features the
new Rotom powered pokedex has a pokemon
snap like ability that lets you grab
pictures of pokemon in the wild finally
it's been confirmed that sun and moon
are set at different times sun follows
the time on your 3ds but moon adds 12
hours to the real world time of day this
will also affect health certain story
events play out sun and moon comes to
3ds on November eighteenth that's not
too far off but you can bet we'll see
even more trailers and information
before launch day to keep up with all
the biggest pokemon news and there is a
lot of it you're already in the right
place
you